mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs
bonjour j'aime bien ça change un petit
peu le style de cuir comme ça
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un produit
dont je vous ai déjà parlé il ya
quelques temps j'ai fait un homme boxing
dessus et maintenant il est temps de le
tester
c'est le djia au mit alors je dis xiaomi
alors ces chiens au mit excusez moi pour
la cent pour la gelée paris c'est pas
que j ai la chance c'est xiaomi et
l'accent voilà donc on va parler de
shiao mire et demi 5 plus le grand écran
le grand modèle
on va faire un test on va tous regardé
du point de vue de l'écran de la vidéo
de la photo by apple doit dire dessus et
s'en va le regarder maintenant
m
bon ce produit il est plutôt cool je
vous ai déjà fait un notebook s'il n'ya
pas très longtemps d'ailleurs la vidéo
est juste là vous pourriez avoir besoin
de faire un petit peu john travolta et
j'arrête signe donc un produit que moi
je trouvais plutôt cool lors d'uen
boxing alors là j'ai eu le temps de
gratter gratouiller de voir ce que
j'aime et ce que j'aimais pas il ya
plein plein de choses à dire sur ce
produit là je le trouve au final pas mal
et puis surtout parce qu'il coûte quand
même moins de 200 euros alors
effectivement à ce prix là on n'a pas
s'attendre à voir un appareil qui fait
des choses dedans et qui va vous
décroché la lune mais par contre il y en
a vraiment dans le ventre
il fait pas mal de choses très
intéressantes à la surcouche de xiaomi
est vraiment intéressant est la première
chose dont je vous parlais peut paraître
complètement déconnecté de ce qu'on
retrouve actuellement au niveau des
smartphones c'est la télécommande
infrarouge
alors moi je suis un petit peu un vieux
dino h léopold school j'adorerais avoir
à des vieille télécommande infrarouge
dans mes portables
c'est vrai que j'ai omis le fait je
trouve que c'est un truc qui pas
indispensable mais qui a un vrai sens
parce qu on a tous une télé on a tous
une box une console ou que sais-je à la
maison saint parres est super
intéressant que son smartphone fasse
office de télécommande universelle
aujourd'hui on vend des smartphones qui
sont capables de piloter votre maison
vous pouvez allumer une ampoule ou peut
faire ce que vous voulez
si vous pouvez même pas gérer de
l'infrarouge c'est un petit peu ballot
lapointe de fer avec le chiot mire et
2005 plus c'est plutôt pas mal
l'ag mais la télé du salon directement
ici j'ai qu'à appuyer sur le petit
bouton rouge est ma télé va s'allumer un
smartphone que je peux tester grâce à
mon partenariat phone points comme je
vous le redis ici alors forcément je
leur fait de la pub parce que c'est
grâce à eux que je peux l'avoir ils ont
des produits à des tarifs très
intéressants donc s'il vous intéresse
vous pouvez y aller sans aucun problème
on va parler de ce produit moi je trouve
qu'il est cool il tourne sous android 7
points un point de nougat la surcouche
c'est une m hi hi hi
9.2 cette surcouche elle est assez
marrante elle a des faux airs de noël ça
va bon c'est pas simple évidemment ce
n'est pas de la rse n'est pas du copier
coller mais bon malgré tout ça me
rappelle un petit peu ios j'ai lu dans
certains tests qui marquait que le
capteur d'empreintes digitales était
plutôt mal positionné qu'on n'avait pas
accès alors je suis pas du tout d'accord
pour moi il est assez plutôt bien
positionné sauf si vous prenez votre
smartphone comme ça où quelqu'un vous
louper comme une toux bas de votre main
et là effectivement vous
un petit peu loin si vous le tenez dans
votre main correctement pour moi vous le
trouvez ici
il est idéalement positionné point super
important pour moi c'est effectivement
le capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
est très réactif
regardez je pose ma page mon doigt 1-2-3
je pose et libéraux tout de suite il le
reconnaît immédiatement
c'est vraiment hyper réactif attention
vous allez voir bruit c'est un nom c'est
hyper actif ça marche très bien pour moi
le capteur d'empreintes digitales il est
vraiment top
le produit en lui-même je trouve qui
tombe plutôt bien alors effectivement le
processeur est pas hyper et 105 irin 659
octas core cadencé à 2 36 gates ce n'est
pas une bête de course mais une fois de
plus on est sur un produit coûte quand
même moins de 200 euros
et moi en tout cas ce que j'ai pu voir
en l'essayant je trouve qui récupère
bien et vous permet de faire pas mal de
chauffe sur des jeux que ce soit sur pas
mal de choses d'ailleurs je n'ai testé
sur le jeu tales of war je trouve qui
met un certain temps assez chargé
mais sinon dans l'absolu pour moi il
s'est quand même plutôt bien la faire
une fois que vous l'avez pris leur
effectivement là c'est pas un jeu hyper
gourmands c'est un petit jeu un petit
jeu tout con vous faites vos trucs il
réagit plutôt bien entre pour moi le
produit est bien j'ai déjà vu plein de
tests tourner sur des jeux légèrement
plus gourmands ça va ça fonctionne ou
pas non plus tendre un truc de fou mais
ça marche plutôt bien truquée sympa sa
taille de l'écran 5,84 pouces ip est
sans ma 19/9 pour moi ça marche voyez là
vous êtes sous le format un peu plus
classique vous avez le phare le ratio
original vous l'agrandisseur forcément
là vous allez bouffer un petit peu de
l'image vous allez vous fais un peu sur
le décor voyez en haut et en bas mais
bon ça dépend des vidéos et des vidéos
qui vont s'y prêter d'autres qui vont
moins s'y prêter
pour moi c'est pas mal effectivement
d'avoir un truc un peu plus immersif les
bords sont assez réduits voilà moi je
trouve qu'il est quand même plutôt bien
réussi ce smartphone on a quand même un
il occupe quand même 95 5% de la face
avant
non moi je trouve assez cool d'ailleurs
sous ça me permet de revoir un peu mon
pote mister pareil en grand d'ailleurs
l'histoire parier ce qui nous regarde
coucou j'espère que tu vas bien
fonctionné et j'ai trouvé hyper cool ça
puisse avoir deux espaces c'est à dire
deux utilisateurs qui peuvent coexister
sur le même smartphone je vous explique
là j'ai mon premier utilisateur qui est
la gca aller ici sur basculer ça va me
demander de mettre ma deuxième
empreintes digitales donc le doigt de
l'autre personne
j'ai mis mon autre doigt ici hop je le
scan et ça me charge mon deuxième
environnement et ça ne chargeons nos
amis utilisateurs donc là je peux tout
avoir en double avoir des applications
différentes avoir un fond d'écran
différents pouvoir stocker
indépendamment je trouve que c'est
vraiment bien par exemple lorsque vous
l'utilisez pour un côté plus perso un
côté plus professionnel ça peut être
vraiment bien ce tout il accueille une
double carte sim
donc pour moi c'est vraiment de
différencier le pro du perso d'abord à
vos contre prono côté vous compte perso
de l'autre ça je trouve ça super
intéressant et puis je sais pas si vous
êtes parents comme moi mais si vous avez
un enfant mais vous pouvez l'ouvrir un
espace lui mettre des jeux bloquer
certaines choses si vous voulez pas
qu'ils y aient accès donc je trouve que
c'est plutôt intéressant voyez qu'on a
qu'à cliquer ici on bascule hop je mets
mon doigt ici et ça ne le change
ça prend quelques secondes et ça me met
voyez sur notre espace hop on s'en fiche
de mes e-mails et ça je trouve ça super
cool autre point que ton super
intéressant vous l'a été dit ici c'est
la possibilité de cloner les
applications avoir de compte twitter
normalement sur twitter on peut faire
coexister deux comptes en même temps sur
via l'appli mais là je vous montre
twitter mais ce que veut montrer
qu'autre chose la voyez là si vous voyez
ma tronche facilement contre perso mon
twitter à moi personnellement et ici
vous avez mon twitter monsieur greu que
j'utilise un mot que j'utilise quasiment
jamais up en prenant les mentions voyez
ici
voilà ça c'est ma tronche sur twitter ça
pas forcément de sens parce que
l'application vous permet de le faire
directement
mais sur ce match a raté pas mal vous
avez votre premier snapshot ici hop
voilà
et vous avez votre deuxième snapshot
justice ira donc ça permet de faire
coexister plusieurs applications pour
l'avoir c'est tout con vous aller dans
les paramètres vous descendez
application clown et ça vous propose les
applications que vous avez clown est
celle que vous pouvez clonés et je
trouve que c'est super bien fait la
version que j'ai c'est la version
globale la version globale elle vous
permet d'utiliser à l'international et
ça vous évite effectivement si vous
achetez un produit chinois de ne pas
pouvoir l'utiliser en france donc ça
c'est plutôt bien et c'est important
alors effectivement attention ou est ce
que vous le commandez vérifiez toujours
avoir une globale version pour pouvoir
l'utiliser sur les bandes en europe pour
pouvoir avoir la 4g et pour pouvoir a
utilisé chez votre opérateur
si vous passez en chine il vous suffira
pas d'acheter le produit il faut
vraiment qu'il soit compatible avec
l'europe
alors maintenant on va regarder un truc
est super marrant c'est la caméra alors
il ya effectivement une caméra arrière
qui est up seule caméra celle fille
effectivement une caméra arrière qui
fait la sphère qui fait le job
pas de stabilisateur alors pour moi qui
ai toujours un peu la tremblote beaucoup
m'ont fait remarquer dans certains tests
si dans la maison il pas le
stabilisateur vous voyez typiquement
pour moi c'est pas un produit qui a fait
pour moi parce que l'image soit toujours
bouger ça va pas être génial par contre
je trouve que d'un point de vue couleurs
le rendu est vraiment bien c'est plutôt
bien fait les zones d'ombré tout est
bien rendue et je trouve que le détail
est là le produit est plutôt pas mal
lorsque vous voulez faire de la photo ou
alors ce que voulait faire de la vidéo
je trouve que c'est plutôt bien fait
c'est assez sexy je vous dis chante
vraiment le fait qu' aucune
stabilisation
on va le faire des petits tests dans
d'ici quelques instants l'extérieur pour
mieux se rendre compte mais je trouve
que voilà sa marque toutefois mal et il
ya une petite particularité mas qui me
fait vraiment mourir de rire
c'est lorsque vous êtes à l'avant vous
allez voir que le scanner ma tronche ça
veut dire mon sexe ça va estimer mon âge
un homme de 39 ans 40 ans merci 41 ans
43 ça va je vais juste cool jusqu'à 50
de hugo des conneries j'ai tout 54 ans
44 ans bordel de bordel de bordel la
chaîne 30 cher tout à l'heure j'ai 31
ans et le manque de lumière
ah ouais faut dire que ça fait un peu
dire il a pas j'ai honte j'ai honte je
viens d'être très vieux d'un coup merci
beaucoup ont racheté félicite pas alors
je vais essayer normalement c'est plus
flatteurs lorsque vous mettez de la
lumière
mais bon là voilà j'ai morflé jeunes 30
54 en règle bon bah tant pis pour moi ça
m'apprendra autre point qui est assez
rigolo vous avez bien évidemment les
filtres ici avec différentes couleurs
alors bien évidemment le mot couleurs
pop simple et tonique rustique glacial
pour ça vous connaissez un c'est un
renouveau des choses qui existent déjà
ailleurs voilà c'est pas on réinvente
pas là on pas inventé la poudre le hdr
pas j'ai mis un truc déformant autant
pour moi à oui y'a même des choses assez
marrant ça voyez j'avais pas vu ça peut
vous déformez compressé et tirer
j'imagine même pas si je le fais sur ma
tête mon avis je vais prendre cher
est-ce qu'on peut le faire ça sur les
têtes up fait de voir à aa highway
magnifique beau résultat
alors là l'ami
pas mal renvoyé et s'assurer mosaïque
miroir bon on s'amuse un c'est pas un
truc passionnant c'est pas un truc de
dingue
hop je vais remettre à l'initial c'est
marrant ça permet effectivement d'avoir
un rendu qui est normalement plutôt pas
trop mal
hop c'est pareil ici je vais le
désactiver voilà ça permet d'avoir
quelque chose qui est pas mal
le hdr je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
vraiment servir à grand chose ici je le
désactive
vous avez un truc qui est assez
intéressant qui est pas mal c'est un
flash à l'avant qui est automatique
voilà là par exemple hop je suis un
homme de quel âge hinden la 38 ans et la
3éme d'agen 40 ans franc mac et est
tellement heureux tout à l'heure d'être
plus zen l'achèvement des goûters à les
41 ans arrête pas là ça me fait mal donc
l'idée d'avoir un flash à l'avancé assez
intéressant dans le flashy tabasse vous
attendez pas à voir un flash hyper cool
qui va être tout doux avec vous ce flash
lite abbas on en prend plein la tête
en mode pro vous pouvez par exemple
avoir une peau qui va être moyenne grain
de peau un peu plus fin bon voilà ça va
un petit peu sur ceux du point de détail
je pense pas que ce soit vraiment un
truc il fonctionne super bien
ne cherchons pas la complexité donc là
on teste la vidéo alors je dis moi le
problème de la stabilisation d'avoir
quelque chose à ces dames chez moi a vu
que j'ai la tremblade ça bouge
alors ici on est éclairée ya vraiment un
éclairage du studio forcément il ya de
la lumière
on va tester maintenant à l'extérieur on
va les voir si c'est intéressant et on
va se mettre dans une donnée un peu plus
d'ombré un peu plus sombre pour aller
voir si ça marche ou pas donc là je sens
la caméra arrière et maintenant faire le
test sur la caméra avant puissant la
caméra avant là effectivement là je vais
vraiment ça me fait une espèce de
compression au niveau de la peau c'est
pas juger après bon voilà ça marche mais
là je suis très éclairé un jeu vraiment
proche d'une source de lumière oui je me
décale un petit peu tout de suite je
suis un peu plus sombre bon ça
fonctionne pas trop mal la ja de
l'allumer un jeu quand même plutôt pas
mal et ça fonctionne plutôt bien
maintenant on va aller voir ça en
conditions naturelles en extérieur il
fait très froid là il doit faire cinq
degrés on a du mal à sortir l'hiver
cailler les miches
je le fais pour vous sur les caméras
avant directement hop en extérieur cette
fois-ci là j'ai un peu de soleil vous
voyez lorsqu'à du soleil normalement
c'est pas trop trop mal s'il me faut un
peu à l'ombre
allons vous allez voir c'est tout est
relatif 1 je suis comme à l'extérieur
donc ça marche la marche le manque de
stabilisation c'est vraiment un truc
flagrant en tout cas chez moi ça se voit
davantage et maintenant on va tester la
même chose mais sur la caméra arrière
le test sur la caméra arrière d'entacher
dans la zone non hop voilà je vais pas m
contre mais devant devant maintenant on
va passer du côté un petit peu plus
éclairés de ce côté là voilà donc là
j'essaye dans la tronche en manque là ça
fait du bien quand même le soleil donc
voyez desquels la lumière ça marche pas
trop mal
maintenant on va regarder un petit pot
en faire un test j'étais rentré à
l'intérieur on va voir si le rendu du
point de vue quelque chose d'éclairer un
univers que tu es beaucoup plus son
pouvoir si ça marche c'est sa télé sans
jamais faire ce test sont différentes
parties donc ici c'est sont tout de
suite des locaux qui sont relâchés dans
le noir je ne rends pas compte
l'achèvement par contre si c'est bien ou
pas si le rendu est cool ou pas là si
nous pouvons vraiment pas là mais je
suis assez sombre on va voir si le rendu
est bien ou pas avoir exactement le même
test maintenant mais sur les caméras en
extérieur maintenant on va rentrer et on
va voir ce que ça dit oui au noir
l'asim 5 mégapixels à l'ouverture je la
connais pas sur l'autre c'est une 12
mégapixels une ouverture de deux points
2 c'est ma vie ça fonctionne je vous dit
de toute façon on est serein smartphone
coûte pas très cher donc on va pas alors
envoyé toute la stabilisation c'est
chaud ça corrige quand même pas trop mal
et ça par contre
voyez les pixels comme ça me fait une
peau dégueulasse alors je crois non plus
une peau de pêche bien c'est le problème
du pixel ça c'est pas la définition
n'est pas super ça une correction
logicielle ça fait un truc hyper pixo
c'est vraiment vraiment old school mais
bon voilà c'est comme ça regardez le
grain de peau
ah mon dieu oh mon dieu le grain de peau
est horrible pour que d'un point de vue
photo d'un point de vue photo vidéo ça
marche plutôt pas mal voyait lorsqu'on a
des photos ici en faible luminosité on a
quand même un rendu qui est plutôt pas
dégueulasse du point de vue vidéo ça
fonctionne un voyez c'est pas non plus
un truc complètement dingue mais ça
fonctionne petite particularité de ce
produit vous avez une radio fm que je
n'ai
jamais réussi à faire marcher voilà
c'est chercher des fréquences plein de
fréquences différentes
c'est autour de chez moi je n'ai rien
rassurez vous je ne suis pas dans un
endroit désertique où il n'y a rien il
ya beaucoup de choses ici mais ça ne
marche pas donc ça point négatif up
trouve que la colorimétrie de l'écran
est plutôt bien la luminosité est bien
alors je peux encore la pousser beaucoup
plus forte
si je effectivement profiter ça marche
bien lorsque vous l'emmenez à
l'extérieur qu'il ya beaucoup de lumière
ça fonctionne bien on voit bien l'angle
de vue est vraiment correct aussi quel
que soit l'endroit où vous vous trouvez
je trouve que c'est vraiment plutôt bien
réussi le produit est vraiment pas mal
l'angle de vision est bien la surcouche
l iihs 9.2 je la trouve vraiment plutôt
intéressante
moi je trouve quand de ce point de vue
là en tout cas y'a omi a vraiment fait
du bon boulot côté sont je trouve que
les haut parleurs sont pas mal
moi je trouve que le son masque plutôt
pas mal je trouve qu'il ya du bon son
alors c'est un haut parleur mono vous
avez ici même si vous avez des petites
parties c'est un haut parleur mono mais
ça fait plutôt bien la faire ça fait un
petit moment que je le teste je trouve
que la prise en main est cool je trouve
que les capteur d'empreintes digitales
marche merveilleusement bien
je trouve que d'un point de vue écran
d'un point du couleurs d'un point de vue
qualité il s'est vraiment bien la faire
les photos les vidéos c'est assez moyen
mais une fois de plus on est sur un
produit que quand même moins de 200
euros
l'ag le produit en 3 giga 32 gigas de
stockage qui coûte pas très cher qui
coûte 100 85 euros vous avez le même en
4 gigas et en 64 go de stockage à 199
euros c'est-à-dire 14 euros de plus à
mon avis faut pas hésiter
voilà voilà un peu ce que je peux vous
dire moi je trouve super vol un peu pour
ce test de ce chien au mit
mi5 plus je vous dis moi je suis plutôt
conquis pour le tarif sococé un produit
qui marche vraiment bien qui a pas mal
de possibilités
la surcouche de chez omis je la trouve
vraiment bien la version 9
et hop on peut faire pas mal de choses
avec le déverrouillage et super la
luminosité bien l'écran est bien le haut
parleur fonctionne plutôt bien
la connectivité est bien il est rapide
voilà les photos vidéos c'est un peu le
point moyens mais une fois de plus on
est sur un produit d'entrée de gamme à
moins de 100 euros
on va pas lui demander la lune mais de
mon point de vue à moi le test est
positif
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
produits de xiaomi est ce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que serait ni 5 plus vous le
trouvez sexy cool intéressant ou alors
carrément pas du tout intéressant
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire j'ai
hâte de voir tout ce que vous allez
m'écrire bien évidemment croyez moi sur
parole jolie tous vos commentaires j'ai
pas forcément le temps d'y répondre
parce que les journaux trond et sont
extrêmement longue mais je regarde
toujours un oeil dessus donc vous pouvez
croire que c'est beau mais c'est des
petits messages
je vais les regarder je vais essayer de
prendre toujours plus de temps pour vous
envoyer des petits mots et si vous avez
des questions vous pouvez aussi
contacter sur twitter @ monsieur gros
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
dites moi ce que vous en pensez mark et
moi tout en commentaire vous avez deux
quarts des habitudes mdc des jolies
pousse à rester connectés à vous abonner
parce qu'on parlait toujours plus et
toujours mieux de teck j'ai plein de
choses hyper cool à voir avec vous d'ici
là soyez sages vous embrasse et à très
bientôt
ciao
[Musique]